conservative accidents  universal healthcare kevin sorbo  sort of like  stumbled across a very prescient idea he  was tweeting about the covet vaccines  if the shots were given away for free  because they're life-saving why isn't  insulin free or chemotherapy or epipens  and of course the answer is they should  be free and of course we don't literally  mean free come on guys we we're adults  we understand that it's free at the  point of service but it's paid for  through taxes we we understand that but  he's he's he's right he's unironically  right those things should be free at  point of service because people's lives  do depend on them  good luck explaining it to kevin sorbo  guys  that guy is gone as alex jones said  about me look at those eyes man that  that's that that dude is gone ladies and  gentlemen